does Maga care more about democracy or
gas prices or maybe more accurately does
Maga care more about democracy or the
promise of lower gas prices when the
current gas prices aren't even very high
a version of this question is what
Chauncey De Vega asks in a very good new
commentary in Salon called is America
ready to trade democracy for cheap gas
that's fascism in a nutshell Americans
understand Wright's Chauncey that
democracy is in dire Peril that doesn't
mean they believe in it or give a damn I
encourage you to check out this piece
written yesterday
he references the New York Times
headline which says voters see democracy
in Peril but saving it isn't a priority
he writes the details are Grim voters
quote overwhelmingly believe American
democracy is under threat but seem
remarkably apathetic about that danger
with relatively few calling it the
nation's most pressing problem
more than one-third of independent
voters in the poll said they were open
to supporting candidates who reject the
legitimacy of the 2020 election because
economic concerns are more urgent 71
percent agreed democracy was at risk
only seven percent said it was the most
important problem in the country so one
of the important things to consider is
that for many of these Maga voters it's
the promise of lower gas prices which
they're willing to trade for democracy
for the will of the people depending who
is in office but when you look at gas
prices you say they're not even really
that high they're down like 30 something
percent from the peak and for the
average vehicle even if they were to go
down another 30 percent you're only
talking about quite literally a few
dollars difference for every full tank
that couldn't really be worth trading
for a functioning democracy could it
but it appears that for many voters
indeed it is and so we are down to the
very end here as it comes to the 2022
midterms uh we're going to have results
starting Tuesday night and I hope you'll
be live with me on YouTube twitch and
Facebook the 2022 midterms may be just
the beginning in fact they almost
certainly will be just the beginning we
will probably learn in the 24 to 48
hours that follow Tuesday's elections
if and how committed are
right Wingers to democracy 2020
suggested the answer is not particularly
committed but we will see very quickly
are they doing this if we won it was
fair but if we lost its rigged thing are
they going to do it again and if they do
it will be a sign that it is now just
sop standard operating procedure for
these folks and that will be yet another
divot in the Democracy that is left at
this point in time I don't know that
they do care about democracy at this
point anymore
uh I think that at this point they just
want to win now we also just want to win
but we want to win by people realizing
their ideas are a disaster we're not
trying to win by just putting in office
people who got fewer votes that is a
critical fundamental difference you
might think the top tax rate should be
38 percent
and you might think it's 42 and I might
think it's 43 and those are reasonable
differences that exist in in reality
but if one of us believes that actually
if my candidate gets fewer votes we
should figure out a way to install them
anyway
that is very different than a
disagreement about about tax policy or
foreign policy or whatever the case may
be I hate I hate the fact that the
answer to Is America ready to give up
democracy because they have been
convinced cheaper gas is more expect
more important I am afraid that the
answer is indeed yes and we will know
much more about that what 72 hours from
now I want to talk a little bit about
this idea of asking questions now we've
talked before
about how I'm just asking questions is
sometimes used to create cover for bad
faith questions destructive questions
corrosive questions push questions like
for example listen I'm just asking
questions if Democrats continue their
communist murder campaign of Republicans
would you still vote for them
guys I'm just asking questions you're
not going to tell me questions are bad
are you we've seen it used in that way
but I want to mention something else
about question and questions and it
relates to our friend Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson asking
questions in and of itself isn't
virtuous
isn't virtuous asking obviously stupid
ridiculous questions meant merely to
fire up low information voters isn't
something we should celebrate but Tucker
is increasingly using this meme
questions are we no longer allowed to
ask questions in the United States
as he likes to laugh if everybody is
free to ask questions about it yeah and
demand real answers if you're
coming up with some sort of crazy theory
about what happened to Nancy Pelosi's
house last Friday instead of yelling at
you or calling you names or telling you
you're a conspiracy not your Alex Jones
Just Produce the police body cam why is
that so hard if you think something
weird was going on in January 6th okay
it's not your fault maybe it's the fault
of the people who are hiding thousands
of hours of video or maybe the fault of
the people telling you something weird
went on when uh okay it's from January
6th why haven't they released that the
onus is on them not the rest of us we're
not the crazy people you're the Liars
okay so a couple different things there
Tucker fundamentally misunderstands
burden of proof If you are going to make
a claim like for example a claim that's
been made many times there was fraud in
multiple States organized by different
people in each state significant enough
that the true winner if it represented
the will of the voters would have been
Trump instead of Biden
it's up to you
if you believe that instead of a of an
obviously politically motivated
right-wing attack on the Pelosi
household in San Francisco last week
what took place was
a lover's quarrel between Paul Pelosi
and his gay prostitute who was already
inside the house at the time of the
altercation you need to produce that
evidence you need to produce that
evidence but let's put a side burden of
proof we shouldn't fall for the Absurd
notion that bad faith absurd questions
should be celebrated because in a vacuum
asking questions is a good thing
I think we're dealing mostly with adults
at least legally to a three-year-old you
might want to encourage curiosity and
all that and you say there's never a
stupid question always I want to hear
every single one of your questions oh
it's a beautiful thing
to a six-year-old when they ask a silly
question you might say that's such a
silly question let me tell you why to a
10 year old you might say hey you know
what let's focus our questions uh uh to
build on what we already know you know
that there's some questions that are
useful and some questions that are just
nonsense but to adults you would say cut
the stupid questions you imbeciles it is
neither good nor righteous to make up
so-called evidence out of the blue claim
that now it is the default official
story we should believe and then ask
other people to disprove your crazy
ideas the immediate assumption should be
why is that the question at this point
in time where is the burden of proof
does the evidence actually fit that
being the question and being put in the
position all the time by these folks to
prove negatives the way they love to do
it's not virtuous it's not to be admired
it's simply nonsense and so let's not
fall for there's no such thing as stupid
or silly questions there are what you
say to a kid about questions is
different than what you might say to
Tucker Carlson or to these Maga people
keep it in mind
one sign that things might be about to
get very dicey with Tuesday's election
is that my pillow CEO and founder Mike
Lindell known as Mike pillow or simply
pillow over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines yeah
he is claiming that he has a real-time
crime desk to monitor deviations and
anomalies of Democrats no doubt
attempting to steal Tuesday's election
listen to what this guy is saying it is
as scary as it is delusional where will
you be election night
in 10
or Frank's speech speech
um I will be there I'm going to have my
we have two Studios and I'm gonna have
the real crime the real time crime
deaths with cyber guys so you can tune
in to Lindell TV and watch and we're
gonna you want to see what's happening
with your candidate or whatever if it's
getting sold in real time if it is
getting stalled in real time
pillows cyber guys will tell you folks
we are screwed this
one and when they do it we're gonna on
the morning of the ninth yep um if ones
are counting ones that are counted
everything's gonna stand out and if they
don't
um here's what we can pray for we can
pray for that the media covers the the
deviations and anomalies and I'm talking
to Fox News Newsmax and the conservative
media they better start reporting
election crime period wow that is a sick
individual or someone who has drank
gallons of his own Kool-Aid I genuinely
don't know you know people write to me
all the time they say Sir tears they're
crying they say is Mike pillow for real
you've interviewed him David is Mike
pillow for real when he says this stuff
we're doing a class
yes I do not know the answer
I genuinely don't know the answer I go
back and forth I've now interviewed him
in longer form interviews multiple times
I do not know whether pillow is
delusional
whether he is knowingly saying things
that aren't true to rile people up
I do not have the answer at this point
in time your guess is as good as mine I
would say at this point so we should be
it I don't I continue to think he might
be admitting to crimes claiming he has
cameras on the polling places I don't
know if any of the stuff he's claiming
is legal or if it's actually happening
but we should pay very close attention I
hope you will be with me live on Tuesday
night
that's my sincere hope I will be live
with election results nationally
we'll be going all night till like 8pm
no I'm kidding we're gonna go we're
gonna go until we have definition quite
frankly
um YouTube tuition Facebook I hope
you'll be with me and remember subscribe
on YouTube folks we're pushing to two
million YouTube subscribers I would love
for you to hit that subscribe button
particularly if you're watching and
don't subscribe there's almost 3 million
of you three million uh we'll take a
quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show is funded directly
by our audience that's just the reality
you know maybe I would love to have uh
something like Steve bannon's gig where
you've just you don't really need to
fund your show you've you've got people
funding it you don't care about your
audience we care about the audience
we've got the bonus show we've got the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show we have the members only
town halls and all of it and you can
access it quickly cheaply and
efficiently by signing up at
joinpakman.com and for just a few more
days until the 2022 midterm election you
can save big with the coupon code big
voting 22. let's get to our live calls
today the most important people for the
show are the viewers and the listeners
without you I'm a guy in a room talking
to no one and it's sad so we take calls
via Discord at davidpack dot com slash
Discord and let's see what is on
people's minds let's start today with is
it Desmond or desmu from Birmingham
yeah it's Desmond Desmond what's going
on today
I'm chilling man good Hey so uh my
question for you was
um it seems to be that there is a trend
to undermine American democracy by the
right as well as things like encouraging
General political violence do you think
that this is a trend that will continue
into the future or do you think that
this is something that will slow down it
will continue unless there is something
that stops IT and says that it's
unacceptable and that is a number of
different words
I'm sorry do you think like worsen or
maybe like pretty much the same it is
now I I think it will almost certainly
worsen Barack Obama at a speech uh
earlier this week in Nevada
um made this point and I think he made
it astutely and accurately which is when
you have one side that generically will
condemn violence when there is violence
but they will coddle and Inspire and
allude to it being an acceptable form of
political speech and then their
followers start to do the violence in
small scale stuff like an individual
attack on Paul Pelosi and in large-scale
stuff like the January 6 Trump riots and
yes the Trump rioters are slowly being
held accountable as their cases are
adjudicated but those who inspired that
event have not been held accountable why
on Earth would they stop to the extent
that they believe it benefits them and
it's good to keep the other side scared
which clearly they believe something has
to happen to get them to stop
okay hey thanks for having my question
absolutely everything things are okay in
Alabama
uh it's I mean I'm in Birmingham so it's
kind of like a blue bubble surrounded in
a sea of red so it's a little different
here compared to the rest of the state
so I can't really speak for the more
rural areas but we're we're chilling in
Birmingham it's nothing too out of the
ordinary right now you can get like a
good uh you can get a good cappuccino in
Birmingham
yeah it's nothing too out of the
ordinary it's kind of like a it's not
like a huge City or anything comparable
to like Atlanta or anything but it's
pretty Normie there's like you know what
I mean there's like nothing too odd
going on I would love to visit someday
hey it'd be cool to see you man all
right Birmingham appreciate the call
very much thank you let's go next to
Grant from Iowa City Grant welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hey David so you might have already
addressed this question in the past at
some point so I apologize if that's the
case but apology accepted
great but what if anything do you think
can be done to regain the majority of
people's confidence in the fairness and
security of the voting and election
process well he the reason I love this
question is that it's based on a false
premise
and I understand why you're you're
asking it this way most people do trust
the election results that we've had in
the United States it's it's not a
majority that doubts the election
results which should make us ask why do
those claims that most people don't
believe get so much attention and
amplification and it's because there is
one side the Republican party that has
abandoned policy and they want to try to
win through hijinks and election
interference and getting votes thrown
out or closing polling places Etc your
question more generically would be what
can we do to increase confidence in our
election systems but you said how can we
get back to a majority we have a
majority who already trust our election
system
right I think I just I asked it poorly I
guess yeah I was more so wondering like
of the people who don't trust it how do
we regain the majority of like those
people sadly it's not simple and here's
why
when critical thinking
is is weakened and diminished in the
United States it creates a vacuum into
which elected officials on any side
could convince their followers of
obviously untrue things
um you look at some of the people who
say they're going to vote for Herschel
Walker despite all of the claims against
them and they go no well he apologized
and he's denying it and it was something
he did when he was young he was 50. uh
and on and on they can explain it away
however and so when you have such a
population that's vulnerable to
non-thinking and disinformation Etc
if the Republican Party decides we
benefit from convincing our followers
that the elections aren't Fair it's very
hard to disabuse folks of that belief so
unfortunately I hate to be such a downer
on this we need to in basically
vaccinate people against falling for
false beliefs like this in the first
place which goes back to what we teach
starting in middle school and in high
school and getting people not to fall
for this stuff in the first place so
it's a very big uphill battle
yeah yeah to the extent one other idea
would be
if Republicans stop believing it's to
their advantage to tell the it was
rigged story
then they would stop doing it and I just
broke a glass wow that was very loud
um and uh but but to the extent that
they continue to benefit from that
they're going to keep doing it
okay very true all right well let's take
my call no prob I I'm actually wondering
how loud that was we do have broken
glass in the studio so we're gonna have
to we're gonna have to deal with that in
a moment but let's continue with that
let's continue with calls for the time
being let's go to Jorge from South
Florida welcome to the show
hey David hi can you hear me I can hear
you how's it going nice meeting you
thank you long time fan
since 2020 actually I've been a fan I
appreciate it I got a question really
like my my family's a little bit
trumpished I have some issues
talking to him about um bias
commentary so one of the things that I'm
just curious to know
but the whole thing with Paul velocity
happening you know um
the poppy going into his house and
breaking in if it would have been the
other way around if it would have been
Trump in his house and someone brings
him into his house yeah and attacks
Melania Trump I'm wondering of the right
media would have you know attacked and
commented on that segment well I you
know the answer to that I know you know
the answer
I do I just wanted to know this is the
culture that is encouraged by democrats
who want to defund the police and let
crime run rampant and open the borders
and
that's it's of course what they would
have done
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly and they
would have convinced a lot of people
with it by the way I mean listen they've
convinced a lot of people that this
entire thing was like a false flag
inside job with a gay lover
uh even though there's no evidence of
that and if it were someone breaking
into Trump's house and you know hitting
Melania with a hammer uh they'd be
calling for Congressional hearings it
would be 24 7 on Fox News I can't even
imagine what they would be doing
that's my thought too yeah I just wanted
to put it out there because I'm like you
know like I want to show people and my
friends and family like do you see the
bias out there like can you really
understand that yeah if it was the other
way around it would just be constant 24
hour like what's going on the world 100
you know so
and I guess that's where I'm frustrated
and I'm I get those pain points like I
do not see reality but so you said your
family is kind of trumpy what kind of
stuff are they saying
exactly that exactly that that you know
like they literally ate it up you know
Elon Musk published it and they said Hey
look it's you know it's it's already
closed out it's you know it was his
lover and I said but wait that doesn't
make any sense like that is your family
Cuban
um yes they are Cuban so you hit on the
nail with that but actually I was
talking to my in-laws who are kind of a
mix they're from other parts of from you
know
South America specifically not Argentina
I hope yes oh no oh my god oh that's
horrifying that's horrible I don't want
to say I didn't want to take it I know
you're Argentina
well listen uh you're bumming me out but
it sounds like you're fighting the good
fight and doing what you can to push
back
I'm trying yeah thank you all right
thank you for the call very much
appreciate that there is Jorge from
South Florida let's go next to Sam from
New York City Sam welcome to the program
what's going on hey thanks so much I'm
sort of had a question about you know I
need to cover some of the Trump rallies
to Marathon for unfortunately they're a
young kid you know three four five that
are there and you kind of skip over that
part I agree with that because I really
do see them as victims of uh again a
very narrow media space where they've
just been fed propaganda
um so what I wonder sort of
theoretically is at what point at what
age in their development do we then sort
of turn and start pulling them
responsible because I really struggle
with that right you have a
three-year-old I'm not going to blame a
three-year-old for having frumpy views
the big forced to wear like a trumpet
but that three-year-old's gonna grow up
still ingesting the same media diet yeah
so is there a point where then we can
start holding that former three-year-old
if possible here's why this is really
tough
if we had a system of Education in the
United States where we knew with
confidence Sam that starting in fifth
grade and then definitely by seventh and
eighth grade and a hundred percent in
high school we were really teaching kids
here's how you think for yourself here's
how you think critically here's how you
evaluate claims here's how you do
research Etc if we did that I would be
very comfortable saying to you listen
by the time kids are 15 we can start to
say
you were responsible for the things you
now believe right that would be that's a
hypothetical but the truth is many
schools don't teach this stuff I visited
rural conservative parts of the country
where people's entire kind of
socio-cultural lives revolve around
their churches and the local shooting
range
if that's what they're exposed to until
they're 18 or ever
at I don't know what the answer is
because they sort of are in a bubble
they were born into indefinitely so that
you know blame I don't know about I
don't know about the word blame
necessarily but I think as people get
closer and closer to age 18 I think they
are more and more independent in all
ways and that would be both legally but
also in terms of the things they believe
I mean listen if we're if you look at
kids at 14
they are still very likely to hold the
same political views as their parents
even at 18 that's still the case because
in general people continue to hold the
political views you're more likely to
hold the political views of the family
you were brought up in that that we know
that that that persists so I don't know
when there's a clean break and we say I
mean listen a four-year-old is a
four-year-old they're not thinking for
themselves about politics a 12 year old
might be depending on how they were
brought up a 15 year old should be but
we can't really be sure I don't know the
answer it's it's a very gray area
yeah no that's exactly how I feel um I
appreciate your nuanced thought on it
but I also just close with uh with risk
of causing some controversy my own
belief and where you get the best bagel
in New York City please
all right absolute Bagel 107th and
Broadway I don't know if you're familiar
I I never get out of there I never get
up there all right well if you ever are
I'm telling you it says
darn good bagel I'm telling you I
believe that's only though so be
prepared listen here's the thing
there's hundreds of places with great
Bagels in New York City you know that's
just the reality and and I know I'm with
you there and there's dozens of places
with great brisket and you know so it's
almost like a little bit of a joke but
where are you on places like for example
Russ and Daughters where like they're
they've become so known and touristy
that it's like yes it's good but like is
it as good as people make it out to be I
I don't know I don't know no you will
never catch me waiting in that like
two-hour line erupting daughters maybe
it's marginally better if someone else
wants to wait for me and let me try a
bite of their pastrami sandwich I'm all
for it but no I avoid all those places
just like I avoid you know Times Square
you know exactly Times Square is just
the worst yep I'm with you all right
on there okay sorry yeah thank you take
care okay Sam take it Sam shot out of a
cannon on the bagel topic and I
understand it I mean it is one of the
foremost issues that that humanity is
contending with right now let's go next
to I I don't know how to say this is it
sake from California am I pronouncing
that even approximately correctly
no that's all right what's the right
pronunciation
um I go well my name is it's a shorter
or nickname I go by it's like sign like
a song The Tool you use and then Chi as
in Tai Chi or something
Sachi Kazi is that right
yeah something it's not it's my answer
about that do you know how to pronounce
it I guess let's start there
um I want to go wait like sock then she
because you know what like the tallest
son and
she hasn't Tai Chi or something all
right well what's on your mind today
um well first I want to say um
conversation on your child thank you
sometimes for me to say it now and um oh
boy sorry yesterday so your con your
connection is going almost like uh like
Lo-Fi uh so what did you have a question
just because I want to make sure I get
to it before we potentially get
disconnected
yeah um okay another question yes um do
you think that the Republicans
um if they were to take over the house
do you think they were trying to make
the us or the United States kind of like
a dictatorship country like
like uh what was the country uh but
North Korea in a way no they they would
not be able to install a dictator so as
horrible as it will be if Republicans
take over the house and or Senate they
will obstruct Joe Biden they will say
horrible things they will continue to
encourage political violence they're
going to do all of those things but they
will not at least in the next two years
turn the us into a dictatorship
online team because like I remember when
Trump was still pressing at the time it
felt like it was going to be a
leadership right to me anyway no no no I
mean listen if you have the president
the house and the Senate then it's a
little bit different
I say okay
Sachi Kazi I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly from California I really
appreciate the call
I'm Paul it's an honor to talk with you
I'm a big fan thank you so much uh very
much appreciate it let's take a very
quick break don't hang up don't hang up
unless you're just mad at me but please
stay on the line because we're going
right back to the phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's
continue hearing from folks in the
audience I want to go next to royland
from Grand Rapids royland welcome what
is on your mind today
hey David nice talking to you again uh
last time I talked about model monetary
Theory but this time I'll keep it with
voting since that's everybody's mind
beautiful
uh first of all thanks for pronouncing
my name correctly it's really rare that
that happens I don't know how else how
else could it be pronounced it seems so
obvious I've gotten Roland Raylin I
don't even know
if yeah people don't look like they can
pronounce the first time I just say Roy
just say Roy beautiful okay fine well
I'm glad to have you here
yeah so quick question
um so I'm trying to get people to vote
but obviously the ballots are all over
the place of confusing with candidates
do you have like any references or
websites that you refer to for just uh
progressively endorsed candidates or
places that are like you know
kind of some kind of list of candidates
that you that people would endorse for a
progressive caucus or anything I
probably should have asked this during
the primaries and not the midterms but
no I don't have any I thought you were
going to ask a place where you can
figure out exactly where you vote based
on your address and can you vote early
and can you vote absentee and all of
these different things I'm not aware of
any central place for like an
endorsement type thing because the
endorsements are made
organizations make it there's no
official Progressive endorsements
there's different organizations which
claim to be the Clearinghouse for who
should be who should be voted for but no
I I don't know that such a central thing
really exists
that's so unfortunate because I have
people that are like ready to vote but
when they get to the things like uh like
I'm in Michigan and uh when you get past
the parts that say like what the
Democrats are they don't really know who
to vote for
um so yeah so listen what I would
recommend is if you just search on
Google
for Michigan ballot 2022. the first
result is a Michigan Secretary of State
website where you put in exactly where
you vote you put in your County uh you
put in the jurisdiction so it seems some
counties like for example you know Bay
County you put in exactly where you are
you even put in your Precinct and then
it will show you your exact ballot your
exact ballot with everything that's on
it as a starting point familiarize
yourself with what you will be voting
for and then like for example you know
in Michigan whatever wherever I'm
looking here there's a proposal to make
some changes to how elections are
financed you can look at that in advance
and and research what it is you believe
about that so these aren't secrets you
know you don't have to wait until
election day and then get all confused
about the things you're voting on just
Google it Google where you live and you
can find the exact ballot you will have
absolutely yeah I was kind of more
asking for like the lazy person you know
because I I'm aware of all this but I
just would love to lend send a reference
to people that are I mean sadly the lazy
thing is to just you vote all for
Democrats or all Republicans in the
races that are partisan which aren't all
of them necessarily there's like
non-partisan male races but there are
shortcuts of people who are looking for
them I don't know that I recommend them
like I said this probably should have
been a question for during the primaries
and not this far into the election but I
haven't had a chance to call since then
but also one more thing I haven't had a
chance to call since you since you had
your uh child congratulations on that
thank you um I do remember an episode
where you kind of like had to address a
brief that some of the viewers have been
giving you about
um ticking time off to spend time with
your children yeah your child and I
think that's just that's so
disappointing as a viewer as a listener
that you had to make those comments
because you're supposed to be like you
know a beacon for Progressive thoughts
and you know paid fraternity leave and
paternity leave in general something we
should all aspire to be so the fact that
you get the ability to do that is you
know I I I a lot of people probably envy
that and I think that on your next child
if you were to take a whole month off
there there's plenty of us that would be
totally understanding and happy for you
nonetheless well I very much appreciate
that royland thank you for making that
declaration I like it
yes all right well you have a good rest
your day man okay you too there's
royland with uh very important questions
from Grand Rapids Michigan yes
understand the ballot that you will be
presented with just Google it you can
find it easily let's go to Anibal from
Guatemala welcome to the program
Hi how are you I'm doing well
okay okay I have a little question
um how did you deal with negationist uh
I am talking about but well in Guatemala
we had a really big world a civil war
some years ago and even today I have
some goldic features
who are talking about how the Glorious
Army of Guatemala
who committed genocide
was too good for us
um they keep us away from the Communists
and thanks to God
all of us are okay now um we are not um
Venezuela uh it's really
ah you think they just deny basic
reality yep
um and even if I say well maybe it's not
God you can see a lot of religious
groups have
um look for the evidence of this and
everything they say something like oh
but you know they were just Catholics or
Jews
sorry I don't know what to say in
English Jesuits
um yes yes
um or everything is the fault of the
Masons and illuminatis yeah
if it's really bad yeah I I don't when
people are just straight up you know
they don't live in in reality it's very
difficult you know there's an example
from Argentina as well where of course
there was as many people know there was
this Falklands War that took place as
they're known in Argentina and the other
day you know the
I I don't want to pretend that there's
literally only one interpretation of
every detail but I think it's hard to
it's hard to deny that that was a
completely idiotic wrong-headed move uh
in Argentina to distract from the
horrors of the military dictatorship and
it got it it was just an absurd thing
for Argentina to be doing and the other
day when it was like the the anniversary
um I saw a news piece that basically
like they just brought in a few veterans
who fought for Argentina in that
conflict and they acted like it was you
know World War II fighting against the
Nazis as opposed to a completely
contrived and wrong-headed
um a propaganda conflict and it's like
if you if that's the alternate reality
you're living in I I don't know that we
can even really talk you know I mean
it's just so disconnected from the the
truth
yes I know let me recommend you a really
great movie uh La Llorona from Jairo
Bustamante not the one about the
aquarium Brothers
okay I will check it out it was
absolutely amazing is even went to the
show list short list of the Oscars well
about that even or president Alejandro
yamate is talking about how how Jewish
Aid is making claims and helping people
um to create an agenda for indigenous
and it all feels so wrong I mean uh so
there are like a
republican idea in Guatemala and they
are talking about how this group of
indigenous people who commit Human
Sacrifice uh are now going to
um
nobody's saying that
um you you just watch
um is obvious
a whole every touch Foundation is
talking with Alejandro yamate and
everything is so obvious then there are
just making the claim about critical
race Theory but in Guatemala interesting
I don't know enough about that but it
sounds interesting and I will research
it I'm pretty sure there are just
Republicans who are helping Alejandro
yamate because they want to use these
idea of critical race Theory everywhere
right
um yeah when all you have is a hammer
everything everything looks like a nail
listen an eval I do have to let you go
but quick question what I know nothing
about the cuisine of your country what
is a what is a typical food item in
Guatemala
oh there are a lot
um soups are some of the greatest uh
things right yeah maybe it means
intactical red
um soup it is amazing is made of chilies
um beef or maybe chicken it's amazing
all right very good I appreciate the
call thank you
you're welcome all right there is Anibal
from Guatemala let's go next where are
we going next let's go to Logan
from San Jose California Logan welcome
sort of yeah there's something weird
going on but I think we can we can make
it work
yeah
oh God
so I'm gonna have to let you go it's
it's not workable the audio just it went
it went very very bad completely nuclear
and and horrifying let's go to Shelley
from Indiana Shelly welcome
hi David my question today was about the
um
uh student loan forgiveness okay
um so with all of the with all of the
people that are against it it seems like
they kind of encourage the lawsuits
against it
um and what they're being a lawsuit
against it right now
um my question is at what point do these
lawsuits that they're encouraging end up
costing more money than it would have to
actually
supported the program I don't know the
answer to that I mean I think the
lawsuits
the lawsuits would have to go on for a
really long time and be
multi-jurisdictional and be very
expensive before they would approximate
the cost of the student debt relief but
I don't even know that that's
necessarily the the best argument to
make for why this doesn't make any sense
it's remember this student loan debt
forgiveness would be economically
stimulative it would free up money
rather than being paid for interest on
loans to be injected into the economy
into businesses of all sorts of
different kinds so you're you're not
making your argument is fine which is
the lawsuits to fight the Forgiveness
cost money and at some point that's
going to add up to a whole bunch of
money it's also that the student loan
debt forgiveness would be very good
demand side stimulus and good for the
economy
yes yeah you're right I agree
um I guess the other question is then
what what do they actually do with the
interest that they're already getting on
from all of these levels and what is
like for all of the years of of the of
the interest that they've already get
God wanted that to have ultimately paid
for it
I'm not sure I understand you're saying
what should happen in the context of the
Forgiveness with already paid interest
well I'm saying like where when they do
collect the interest you know because
I've been paying online school loans for
20 years right so you're figuring you
know oh it's just it's just it's profits
or it goes back if they're government
loans then it goes back into the
government coffers I mean it's just like
any Debt Service
right so then at that point wouldn't
there be like a surplus to where they
could just pay you know what I mean
where it could just be paid for to begin
with
at this point in time so it's like all
of these loans overall this year all
these oh you're saying just pay off the
current loans with the interest that
they've already collected over the years
correct oh I see yeah I mean that money
has been spent of course but you're I
the idea of what you're saying is not
crazy which is a ton of money has
already been made on the interest on
these loans what what happened to it it
was spent on other stuff is the answer
Shelley
right okay all right well thank you very
much I appreciate your time I appreciate
it things are okay in Indiana
oh yeah they're really good I can't
honestly I can't tell if you're kidding
uh no it's good right now I'm I'm
actually kind of nervous about it
Tuesday yeah you know because I mean
it's a red state so you know you get to
know what you shouldn't escape the dog
but
um you can always hope for the most and
no doubt you will be voting I'm sure
absolutely all right Shelly always great
to hear from you thank you all right
thank you David all right there goes
Shelly in Indiana voting that's what you
call a likely voter she's she's gonna
vote I can just tell she's going to vote
you can count on Shelley's vote uh that
does it for calls today we're going to
go to a break I appreciate every
single one of you who has signed up on
the YouTube channel recently approaching
2 million subscribers I appreciate
everyone who called in even those I did
not get to
but we will take calls again very very
soon
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's get right to the mailbag the last
mail bag before the 2022 midterms you
can email info at davidpackman.com
sometimes we'll highlight a YouTube
comment or a Twitter message or Facebook
message it really could be anything but
it's mostly email and the email address
is info davidpackman.com let's start
today with a message from Fred no this
is the wrong one that's for later here
is the one I wanted to start with
um David Dear Mr Pacman they say I was
attempting to listen on YouTube to the
fetterman Oz debate however your
constant comments and biased
interjections and opinions are extremely
troubling are they really troubling I
should be careful are you wanting to
convince your listeners to follow your
to follow your partisan views
not sure how you can be a leader of a
show in this capacity and expect to be
successful as a reporter you should be
more balanced and especially not give
your comments this is another right
winger
who doesn't have a clue what's going on
I am not a reporter this is a commentary
show this show can only be successful if
I give my opinions now am I trying to
convince people whatever I'm just giving
my opinions it's not troubling that an
opinion person gives opinions and in
fact it's not about expect to be
successful we've got nearly 2 million
subscribers across all of our platforms
actually more like 2.3 2.2 million
across all of our platforms so there are
people who are Furious when I give my
opinion
but that's what the show is and again
it's that lack of media literacy there
is no news show here this is an opinion
show it's an opinion podcast where I
give my opinion I got another email
about the debate coverage and we've been
getting a lot of these because what
happens is
people look for the debate
and sometimes when you type in you know
Oz fetterman debate
our live stream can come up in the first
few results on YouTube and so people who
have no clue about our show will just
click over to it and then they stumble
across me and here I am making comments
how dare I and so people get confused
and they write in and they prefer me to
just sit there silently not saying
anything uh Joe S who
um misspelled his own name
um after listening and watching you on
side screen it is very well seen that
you are a demo rat
I believe what this and I believe this
is Joseph
and what Joseph is trying to say is that
after watching me
on the side of the screen alongside the
debate
it became obvious to him that I am a
Democrat now I I know I'm correcting six
or seven different things there to come
up with that interpretation but I feel
like it's probably accurate I am not a
Democrat and if you want someone who
just says nothing during the debates
there are endless other free streams
that you can find
um one more and this isn't actually
interesting and productive comment about
the debates twitchell says why is it
after a debate where the Democrat
destroys the Republican nothing changes
with polling but if a Democrat doesn't
do well the polls tip towards the
Republican it would seem swing voters
would be the reason but why are
Democrats held to a higher standard this
is absolutely the case and I know that
there are so many right-wingers who will
reject the notion that Democrats hold
candidates to a higher standard than
Republicans it is undeniably true in
every way let's talk through it Donald
Trump could never have been the
Democratic nominee
Democrats would not have accepted an
obvious con man grifter
from the business world who isn't even
particularly good at business but he was
just given a great head start with a
small loan of a million dollars and much
more help with his debt
Democrats never would have accepted
Trump as a nominee because their
standards are higher I'm not a Democrat
but I'm just telling you that that's the
reality the only electorate that would
be so low information and bamboozle-able
that Trump could trick them into
nominating him is the Republican party
because their standards are
significantly lower their standards are
do you claim to be against abortion even
when you're obviously not and Trump did
that do you claim to be religious even
when you're obviously not Trump did it
okay can you attack the right people to
make this way a Mexican rapist and all
this stuff Trump did those things the
standards are way lower
I have to tell you it's similar to a
fault even with like the sexual assault
stuff where Republicans will often
defend their own when they are accused
of sexual assault and misconduct
endlessly whereas if anything Democrats
are too quick to condemn remember the Al
Franken situation what Al Frank the
tasteless joke that Al Franken
participated in was absolutely in poor
taste but immediate demands for Al
Franken to resign which he did Democrats
arguably went too far because their
standards are so much higher than those
of Republicans so that's why the debates
matter in the way that twitchell is
saying astute observation Allen wrote In
this depresses me okay I I this really
depresses me Alan wrote in and said you
say you want subscribers
you say it's free
there is no way to subscribe without
paying
what kind of scam are you running oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as big listen
as I've said before
it is free to subscribe to our YouTube
channel
we have
over a million and a half YouTube
subscribers as much as it would be
amazing to have a million and a half
paid subscribers we don't okay it is
free to subscribe on YouTube
it is free to subscribe on YouTube you
just hit subscribe it's free I've said
subscribe to the podcast
it is free to subscribe to the podcast
we produce it every day every weekday
and it is free it's on iTunes Spotify
etc etc
the one thing that you pay for is to
become a website member yes you do pay
for that but folks I'm not scamming
anybody
it's really free to subscribe on YouTube
it is really free to subscribe to the
podcast
it's free to like us on Facebook to
follow on Twitch all those things are
free but to become a website member you
do pay all right please please please
let's be clear
I can't tell whether this email is
serious but it seemed like it was
as I mentioned last week we are working
on a white paper
with techniques for how to talk about
politics with people in your family or
co-workers whatever the term white paper
is a typical well-known term I got an
email from someone saying my opinion but
I would never call a document a white
paper it sounds very kkk-ish I do love
your show besides this mistake I hope I
hope yes I'm deliberately using a racist
term white paper folks I don't know if
this is serious a white paper is a
completely established and well-known
term it's an informational document that
a company uses to highlight something to
highlight research about an issue or to
highlight a product or a service or a
market opportunity or whatever it's it's
a completely
benign banal term it's it's a white
paper I don't know if this viewer
genuinely thinks that it might be a
racist term
I I just got to move on folks I can't I
can't even deal with it okay it's it's
just a white paper Raymond wrote in
about my interview with former
Scientologist Mike rinder now Raymond is
a Scientologist it might not Shock you
to hear
that Raymond isn't happy with my Mike
rinder interview
Raymond wrote in David I watch your
channel for info on recent political
events but your recent interview with
Mike rinder is one-sided you have
someone who's trying to make money on
his experiences with Scientology I don't
see you trying to get to the other side
of the coin and interview an executive
from Scientology or better yet why don't
you pay a visit to a church of
Scientology so listen
um
no Scientology executives are going to
come on the show
first of all and secondly visit a church
come on dude give me a break at this
point I started to think maybe this is a
Scientologist seems to me Mike has a
problem with the management of the
church and instead of straightening out
his disagreement but air his differences
on your program and write a book to make
money yes that sentence makes no sense
but I'm reading it as written I gave you
more credit than maybe you deserve if
you don't give both sides the same
platform I have been a Scientologist for
43 years there it is and has changed my
life and gave me the tools to deal with
life successfully
um I've researched all of those tools
they're all a scam I hate to tell you
Ray
um ray goes on to say currently and for
about 15 years we don't always agree
with the upper management of the church
but to go to the media and take your
disagreements is irresponsible
so David I challenge you go find out on
your own either visit a church find out
yourself or read a book and see for
yourself I dare you LOL sincerely right
I've read I've read five books about
scientology I've interviewed 10
scientologists I've seen 10
documentaries about scientology have I
visited a church no
would the sanitized experience I would
get if I was even allowed to visit a
church really tell me anything about
scientology no
but I understand
scientologists don't like interviews
critical of Scientology that question
the cult
Fred wrote in and said David I've got to
say for this to be a progressive show
I have been shocked that you have not
covered the Arkansas governor debate
where Sarah Huckabee Sanders is going
against an MIT PhD Democrat Chris Jones
who is the epitome of form over
substance and Pac-Man show ideals in
many ways their debate was today and it
will re-air tonight so listen I I hate
to kind of like end on a negative note
here
we can't cover every debate
that race is not even close the Arkansas
gubernatorial debate AR Governor polling
RCP it's it's like crazy
um yet Sarah Huckabee Sanders is winning
by double digits okay it's it's I get it
Chris Jones is an interesting candidate
we streamed like 15 debates mostly close
races races that could end up making a
difference in the balance we just can't
do everything we can't do everything and
that race isn't close would I love to be
able to cover more sure
but we've got to pick and choose so I'm
sorry Fred but it it is not an
indication of any kind of our
Progressive stature that we were not
able to cover that debate all right info
davidpackman.com
send in your thoughts for the mailbag we
have a great bonus show coming up for
you today which you can instantly access
by signing up at joinpackman.com
thank you